[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i remember when i remember i remember
when i lost my
mind there was something so pleasant
about that place
even your emotions have an echo and so
much space
[Music]
i just knew too
does that make me crazy
[Music]
does that make me crazy
does that make me crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well i think you're crazy
[Music]
i think you're crazy
i think you're crazy
[Music]
is thinking
[Music]
if there's no coincidence
[Music]
but maybe i'm crazy
[Music]
maybe you're crazy
baby we're crazy wow hmm
don't wish it away don't look at it
like it's forever
you and me i could honestly say
that things can only get better
[Music]
and while i'm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
children living like lovers
rolling like
[Music]
and i guess that's why
[Music]
[Music]
cry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
under the cover
[Music]
one two
one two
this is scary everybody we are
absolutely rounding the corner go ahead
uh yeah we're gonna see uh probably at
the white house later on this evening
see how it all works out
the voters taking place and we'll see
how that works
no not a lot of it just a very nice
event
fire between azerbaijan and armenia
he's holding the ceasefire is home
we'll see you over at the event
was i offered no but we'll have the
vaccines very soon
the vaccines are in full development and
we're going to happen very soon
you don't have them yet they haven't
been approved yet
but they're going to be they're going to
be approved very soon thank you
all right guys
oh
[Music]
baby take my hands
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i love you so much
[Music]
[Music]
i love you so much
[Music]
when your day is
[Music]
you sure you've had enough
don't let yourself go
cause everybody cries
[Music]
everybody hurts
[Music]
sometimes
sometimes everything is wrong
[Music]
now it's time to sing along when your
day is
[Music]
[Music]
think you've had too much
cause everybody hurts
to comfort
[Music]
everybody hurts
[Music]
feel like you know
[Music]
days and nights are longer
you think you've had too much
[Music]
what everybody
[Applause]
but heard everybody cries
[Music]
everybody hurts
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
times
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we got it together
we've definitely got our pain together
isn't that nice
i mean really when you're really sick
[Music]
nobody but you and me
we've got it together
[Music]
and the answer to
[Music]
i kinda wonderful
that's what you are i know
there's only only one like you
there's a way they could have made two
yeah you're all i'm living for
your love i'll keep forever
[Music]
get you
[Music]
can't you see it you
you make me feel this way
you're like a fresh morning zoo
on a brand new thing
i see so many ways that i
can love your
please please please
please
[Music]
baby you did me wrong
[Music]
got me wrong
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
i love
[Music]
i wanna be a man
[Music]
i love you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
after my sentence
[Music]
[Music]
i've
[Music]
my
[Music]
we are
[Music]
we are the champions
i've taken my
[Music]
rosie no pleasure crew
i consider it a challenge
[Music]
my
[Music]
the
friends
we are the champions
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my god
[Music]
every man wants to be
[Music]
he's a macho muscles
[Music]
hey
i got to
hey
is
[Music]
he's on
you can best believe that he's a macho
man
[Music]
[Music]
i have to be
um
my body
first
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
is
[Music]
i'm
up
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where there's pride in every american
[Music]
heart
who gave them
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
down
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
so thank you very much allentown thank
you very much allen
eight days you believe that eight days
from now we're going to win the
commonwealth of pennsylvania
and we are going to win four more great
years in the white house
[Applause]
[Music]
i want to begin today by discussing
an issue of existential
importance to pennsylvania very very
important
last week sleepy joe biden made perhaps
the most shocking admission ever uttered
in the history of presidential debates
in other words he blew it on live
television
91 to 9. did you say that 91. did you
know what that means
91-9 but we won't talk about that in
front of the fake news
[Music]
joe biden confirmed his plan to abolish
the entire u.s oil industry
that means no fracking no jobs no energy
for pennsylvania families
texas he wants to go wind
let's go wind let's go have brown hats
blackouts all over pennsylvania all over
the country he wants to go in
he wants to go with windmills that are
made in germany and china
[Music]
and some big big carbon into the air
when they're making them you know that
right
from a different continent but that's
okay biden's plan
is an economic death sentence for
pennsylvania's energy sector i
i mean i think you all know that did you
see it though do you believe it
and even the anchor who i thought did a
very good job by the way
kristen i thought she did a very good
job she said
why do you say that remember that why
are you saying that why do you say
that he will eradicate your energy and
send pennsylvania into a
crippling depression
somehow that doesn't sound good mr
congressman does okay
the biden energy is shut down and he
wants to shut down the whole country
and we're rounding the turn you know all
they want to talk about is cobit by the
way on november 4th you won't be hearing
so much about it
kobe toby tobin
[Music]
today let's talk about covert all over
europe right europe spike they don't
talk about that
now we're rounding the turn and we have
the vaccines coming out very soon years
ahead of schedule if he would have done
it
like he did the h1n1 swine flu one of
the worst handled
that was an epidemic it was a disaster
he had no idea what the hell he was
doing but you know that
the biden energy shutdown would inflict
deep pain and misery on pennsylvania
mass layoffs constant blackouts and
brownouts soaring gas prices
nice to have that two dollar gasoline
isn't it
[Music]
surging energy bills no air conditioning
in the summer no heat
during the winter and no electricity
during peak hours let's watch
president trump on television i'm sorry
we won't be able to do it
the wind isn't blowing today darling we
won't be
no it doesn't it doesn't it does empower
those big
factories that we're opening up all over
the country biden's running mate
kamala harris so
did you see her last night on television
with the laughs
she was laughing at a horrible question
about her she just laughed she found it
so funny
most liberal senator she's the most
liberal senator by far she's
more liberal than crazy burning even
sponsored the 100 trillion dollar green
new deal
the green new deal i don't think so the
green new deal would be an economic
disaster for our nation certainly for
this state
biden and harris have a pledge to join
and rejoin the
paris look you know about paris the
paris climate accord
one of the great disasters of all time
just call up france
how's paris doing shipping your energy
jobs to foreign polluters
all over china all over the rest of the
world and you know it was hard bringing
it back we brought our jobs back a lot
of our jobs are coming back now
you know speaking about jobs i want to
thank the people that own this plan
you know you have a governor named tom
wolf i guess
this thing was set up just a few hours
ago that's why it's so incredible that
people across the street trying to get
it
this was set up because your governor
made it almost impossible
for us to find any site normally we
would have had an airport
we would have gotten in we would have
had to i mean this is really a nice
place
no i want to thank the trucking company
they're great they're supporters
[Applause]
but we just found it a little while ago
because they were shut out we had a deal
it was a deal and they broke the deal
headed by
governor tom wolf who's got your whole
who's got your whole commonwealth shut
down
whole commonwealth is shut down
although probably on november 4th it'll
open they'll announce on november 4th
did you see the one governor said no i
think we should be open by around
november 4th
thank you you know they think they're
going to inflict harm in bad numbers
our numbers are so good our comeback
numbers are the best
anywhere in the world doesn't matter
but you know what it does inflict
tremendous harm in the people that are
shut out of their jobs
that are going to lose their jobs with
suicides and drugs and
alcohol and all the problems so tom wolf
uh
next time give give us a little notice
governor
and i'll remember it tom i'm going to
remember it tom
hello mr president this is governor wolf
i need
help i need help you know what
these people are bad we we go out of our
way regardless republican democrat when
they have a problem
but he shut us out and he tried shutting
us out of two other venues you know we
have
three of these today in pennsylvania
and these just came out you know i have
to say because i watch
and the fake news there has never been
anything like what's happening now
but these just came out so rasmussen
just came out
trump is leading you know that's been
one of the most accurate polls
you don't read it
in fact the pollster called us yesterday
said you have really good numbers
but they won't accept them when we put
them out they don't put them out unless
they're negative the press doesn't put
them out can you know
this is serious and how about big tech
how about the biden scandal and they're
not even covering it
they don't want to talk about it
and by the way that's a real scandal
and the press doesn't want to write
about it except for the new york post
the press won't write about it
and big tech won't take it
people have no idea
what's going to happen in pennsylvania
know pennsylvania don't forget i went to
school in pennsylvania
i went to school in pennsylvania college
and
i know it much better than he does you
know
he's always talking about i grew up
right i grew up in pennsylvania
he grew up nowhere he didn't grow up
no did you watch him in 60 minutes last
night
did you see yesterday when he called me
george no i don't know if i liked you
no no not george
what a mess what a mess
no he called me george i don't know if i
should be insulted or happy about it
it's sort of insulted it's the first
time that's happened to me
logan now but the polls just came out
it just came out so let me tell you the
real polls okay because we feel we're
winning
almost easily but you don't hear that i
watched television today
purposely to see what was going on so it
started out cnn is the worst but i hear
the guy
[Applause]
i hear at t is finally getting smart
and they're going to fire the head of
cnn that's what i hear
zucker but you know what look at this
so rashmusen was very accurate last time
like one of the
top two or three rasmussen
trump approval rating 53 and 52
53
so in another poll we're leading in
nevada
that's nice we're one up in nevada we're
way up in texas despite what you keep
hearing
five up in texas i think we're much more
than that if you listen to the governor
of texas who's
great in ohio we're way up
by four or five points five points in
florida we have it down as four
up in florida that's a lot for florida
so in florida rasmussen that's a i
rasmussen both these are all different
that's a raspberries and 50 to 46 were
plus four and four
you don't hear these numbers right you
hear these guys get on television
florida is going to be very tough no
we're winning in florida we have crowds
but you don't hear it we're nicely up
five up in georgia
landmark let's go landmark five up in
georgia
you don't hear that i heard today he's
losing injury now with not losing in
georgia we're going to win by much more
than five
in arizona we're nicely up really nicely
up very good
we're winning big in iowa but we should
be with what i do for the farmers got
them 28 million
dollars from china
in montana we're so far up they don't
even they shouldn't even have the
election
likewise in utah so far up we're
plus 12 plus 15.
[Applause]
[Music]
and in west virginia with 20 up 20
points up
these are just came out they came out
today
and then in a head-to-head with sleepy
joe biden on a national basis i'm i
am really into the states because you
know you run remember hillary used to
complain
but i never did a national you know
winning i think winning the
vote overall vote is almost easier than
the electoral college
but you remember last year she'd
complained she used to
she used to campaign in the wrong states
the next year but they probably learned
but in the national poll
we're leading against sleepy joe biden
we're leaving and that's harassment
head to head no we're leading
we're leading head-to-head against
sleepy joe so i just thought i'd do that
remember in the old days four years ago
i used to read the polls i'd drive them
crazy
and they'd say oh that's not right i
turned out to be right
so i want you to hear it i it's on
television now it's the only way we get
it on because then i'll put it on
they're fake and they're corrupt people
yeah
they're corrupt i mean i watched
i never watched cnn but i had to see it
this morning
to see so i watched them for a little
while i watched msdnc
owned by comcast right msdnc
i watch and you watch these polls and
you say
oh this is terrible they're fake polls
they're fake
they're total these are real calls we're
going to win in florida
we're going to win in pennsylvania i
think
[Applause]
i mean look at this venue you have
thousands of people across the street
that couldn't get in they couldn't get
in because
honestly uh secret service wasn't that
well equipped they didn't expect because
we just set this place up
we just set it up and think of it
so we have a venue and the governor that
counts the ballots
right the governor counts the ballots
and we're watching you governor very
closely
in philadelphia we're watching you a lot
of bad things
a lot of bad things happen there with
the counting of the votes
we're watching you governor wolf very
closely we're watching you
but the same guy that makes it
impossible for us to get a venue we just
got this thing
literally hours ago and to have people
across the street trying to get in is
amazing
i mean it's amazing which tells you
and i don't know if you saw the ohio
route we had
we had 35 40 000 people
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you
now one of them had a uh a guest this
morning i really watched it for this
reason i mean
i had to get looked it started off
covered kobe cove
don't go don't go and vote don't go and
vote you know who's not voting the
democrats they're not voting
you know if you look at some of these
early polls so we're supposed to be way
down in the initial week
because it's the fake ballots right the
phony ballots that are all crooked as
hell
and then we catch up but we have states
where we're leading in early voting
that's trouble because we win everything
from here on in we win everything
just get out there and vote or if you
have an absentee send it in but you know
what there's nothing
like getting out and voting i did it two
days ago
[Applause]
and it was so good you know i went in
florida in palm beach i said
okay i'm here to vote and the woman was
fantastic
sir do you have identification
[Applause]
i said just happen to have my passport
sir do you have any additional
identification i do
i do she said thank you very and she was
good i mean she was doing what you have
to do
she was good she was totally good
i hear this guy so so she did a great
job
and you know what it was a beautiful
thing because there's no way you can
cheat
i mean that then they said here do this
and here sir you can you know they give
you a booth you sit down you
do what you have to do you get up they
fold it
they put it in then you put it in the
machine yourself they don't want to
touch it
it was so professional there's no way
you can cheat
with these ballots who's sending them
who's receiving them
who's bringing them back who's signing
them it's ridiculous
it's the only way we can be it's the
only way we can lose in my opinion
is massive fraud and that's what
that's what's happening because all over
the country you're seeing it
thousands and thousands of ballots how
about the military ballots that were
thrown into a
garbage can
with the name trump on it so all we can
say is law enforcement is watching
nevada
it's watching philadelphia and
pennsylvania by the way but philadelphia
in particular
because they had a lot of strange things
happen over the years in philadelphia
and we're watching your philadelphia and
we're watching at the highest level
[Applause]
and we're watching the democrat governor
who's got his state
shut down a great state north carolina
has got it shut down
we're watching north carolina we're
watching michigan
so that's another one we're leading by
two points in michigan right
hadn't been won in decades until i
wanted four years ago we're leading in
michigan
and we should be i brought a lot of car
business and brought a lot of car plans
and
they hadn't had a plan built in 42 years
or something
and we brought a lot of plants in you
hear that jet you hear that
that's one that's a brand new beautiful
f-35 jet
[Music]
[Applause]
stealth that's why you can't see it
that's super stealth actually joe biden
is a die-hard globalist who wiped out
your steel mills
you know it better than almost any place
in this country
close down your factories kill your coal
jobs
outsource your industries and support it
every terrible and disastrous trade deal
for the whole i mean for for 47 years
this guy's
been there you're still in the debate
did anybody watch the debate
but did you see his my standard answer
joe you've been there for 47 years why
didn't you do
right and you left three and a half
years ago joe so it's not like it was 25
years ago you left
why didn't you do it joe you know he's
talking about oh i would have done this
with a pandemic
and yet he had the worst his chief was
there
said that he and himself the chief they
were grossly incompetent they had no
idea what to do
and now they're telling us how to handle
a much more lethal
problem amazing i wonder if that chief
of staff is still around
you know he probably said it when he
assumed joe couldn't win
right you know when joe ran because he
was always one percent joe
we used to call him one percent joe
and then he ran and now he's at 50
percent
you know where he's at 50 right up there
he's at 50.
and he ends up winning tell me is
politics a strange game
he was a cheerleader for nafta which was
a
disaster for your state and he
enthusiastically voted for china's entry
into the world trade organization
decimating your manufacturing and
enriching china it's really what made
china he voted for it
pennsylvania lost almost 50 percent of
its manufacturing jobs
after biden's nafta and china disasters
and it wasn't only him but it was the
thinking that was the thinking that's
what they want decade after decade vote
after vote
joe biden sleepy joe has betrayed
pennsylvania
how the hell can you vote for him is
this a serious how can you vote for this
guy
congressman how do you vote for this one
look look look he almost got through the
debate
i wouldn't say he was winston churchill
but it was okay
and then we got him on the last question
i said do you mean
you're against oil yes i'd wean it out
i said pennsylvania texas
are you watching you have no choice okay
[Applause]
if you stop fracking if you stop
fracking which he's against
you know remember he'd say i'm against
fracking
i will ban for he did this for over a
year we got
we only have about 100 clips we're going
to play some of them for you but here's
here's the thing
i don't want to play them all we don't
have enough time in the day
but you don't have to take my word for
it because you know what
because it's pennsylvania i did a
special
television like cecil b demille i did a
really special little treatment for you
the late
great cecil b demille here's joe on two
things security
and fracking you gotta believe you're
not even gonna believe it where is your
screen
the screen cost us a fortune so i hope
you enjoy it
my problem is i bought it i'm supporting
nafta
because i think it is a positive thing
to do and i do not pretend to be an
expert on
international trade matters when you ran
for president
and when barack obama ran for president
you both said you would renegotiate
nafta
you didn't trade agreements like nafta
and permanent normal trade relations
with china which forced american workers
to compete against people making pennies
an
hour has resulted in the loss of 160
000 jobs the president is absolutely
right when he says
that china has been cheating for 25
years and that bill clinton
didn't do enough about it george w bush
didn't do enough about it barack obama
didn't do enough
how exactly are you going to negotiate
that what magic wand do you have
a rising china is an incredibly positive
development
for not only china but the united states
and the rest of the world
rising china is a positive positive
development
it is in our self-interest that china
continue to prosper
we want to see china rise china is a
great nation
and we should hope for the continued
expansion
china is not our enemy we talk about
china
is going to eat our lunch come on
man they're not bad folks folks china's
not a problem
allowing china into the world trade
organization which you supported
extending most favored nation status to
china which you supported
that those steps allowed china to take
advantage of the united states
by using our own open
trade deals against us oh do you think
in retrospect that you were naive about
china no
today we're finally ending the nafta
nightmare and signing into law
the brand new u.s mexico canada
agreement
very special listen it's hard to
overstate the importance of the usmca
this is the single biggest bipartisan
legislative victory for this president
and this administration it is a huge
deal wage growth is better
than it has been since 2009. that means
it is better than it has been
for seven out of eight of the years that
obama was president
the new usmca has powerful protections
to keep
auto manufacturing jobs since the
election we've created
41 000 brand new motor vehicle and parts
jobs
but doesn't he deserve some credit for
that it's better the us mta is better
than that
though it is better than nafta
never said i oppose frackie you said it
on tape
i did show the tape put it on your
website i'll put it on put it on the
website
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including coal and fracking
in the biden administration no
we would we would work it out we would
make sure it's eliminated
i guarantee we're going to gain fossil
fuel
no more no new fracking
i'd gradually move away from fracking
and
i think it's critically important on day
one that we end
any fossil fuel leases on public lands
what about say stopping cracking and
stopping
they want to do the same thing i want to
do they want to phase out fossil fuels
and we're going to phase out fossil
fuels
there's no question i'm in favor of
banning fracking
in terms of business that's the biggest
thing because basically what he's saying
is he is going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
texas would you remember that
[Applause]
pennsylvania
[Music]
so will you remember that pennsylvania
by the way who has gone who's voted here
so far
oh that's good because you know
pennsylvania is a very late
voting state which i like actually for
obvious reasons i like that
so that's all so okay who has not voted
yet
who doesn't intend to vote who's not
going to vote
oh you better say that you'd be in big
trouble in this one
so who is going to vote for trump
see that's why i brought all that
expensive equipment because it's easier
than me saying it right
no it's great that's something brand new
just a couple of days and we only bring
it to certain locations okay
and even though we got shut out of our
main by your governor here
governor
but we brought it here but isn't that
very descriptive isn't that better than
me telling you he said this and he said
that
there it is he also said by the way he's
going to cut your social security you
saw that yesterday right
in 2016 pennsylvania voted to fire this
corrupt political establishment and you
elected an outsider is your president
who is finally putting
america first america
with your vote we will continue to fight
the america
look we're gonna fight we are going to
ready we are going to fight for the
american workers and
we're going to lower drug prices support
your police we're going to support you
we're going to protect your second
amendment which is totally under siege
but don't worry about it as long as i'm
your president you don't have to worry
about your second amendment look at what
i've done so far
it's been under siege i can tell you
that we're going to defend our borders
they don't want to have borders they
want to have open borders
you know the wall is almost complete
right they want to have
and we have the strongest border we've
ever had right now
they want to have open borders and if
you have
open borders you don't have a country
you don't have borders you don't have a
country
almost finished very shortly it's going
to be finished we just hit
400 miles of water
and this is a wall that's exactly what
border patrol
and all of the law enforcement people
wanted we built them i said you know
could you take it easy this is getting a
little expensive
load it up it's loaded up with equipment
and wires and everything else
in addition to the wall because as you
know the democrats say
walls are obsolete right i said no walls
and wheels will never be absolute
walls everything else is going to be
obsolete
and sure we want to ensure that more
products are proudly stamped with the
phrase
a beautiful phrase made in the usa
right made in the u.s
we are going to deliver record
prosperity epic
job growth we're doing it already 11.4
million jobs over the last few months
there's never been a time in our history
where we put that many people to work
that quickly
groundbreaking therapies and safe
vaccines that quickly end the pandemic
it's ending anyway we're rounding the
turrets ending anyway
but the vaccines are going to be
incredible they'll be very quick
if somebody else were president you'd
get a vaccine in about four years from
now
normal life that's what we want right
normal life we want normal life
we're just wondering it's happening very
quickly and next year will be the
greatest economic year in the history of
our country
i gave working families record-setting
tax cuts
biggest tax cut in the history of this
country and this guy's running on tax
increases i never saw it i said it
yesterday where i was with a great group
i was in new hampshire you should do
very well there
unless you watch television he will not
win
then you get polls like you're eating
and i say why do they keep saying that
because you know what they are they're
suppression polls
they make you depressed and by being
depressed you say darling
we really like our president a lot but
let's just go have dinner and then we'll
come home
and we'll come home early and watch the
results
and that didn't happen four years ago
you said darling he may not win based on
television but let's go vote anyway
and then they had in probably the most
exciting evening maybe in the history of
television
right sure beats any sporting contest
even espn admitted that there's never
been anything like this
then you went donald trump has won the
state of florida right remember
and they said donald trump has just won
the state of ohio so you know with ohio
we went i mean we went for a year
you have to win in ohio you cannot win
unless you win in ohio
and they go donald trump has just won
the state of ohio but he was the problem
won by eight points this was not like
that was like the biggest victory they
couldn't believe it
and they said there's something going on
here but i'm sure this is just
remember with the hand john king the
hand shake it
hand started getting a little shaky no
it got a little bit shaky and then we
won north carolina we won
excuse me a place called pennsylvania
[Applause]
remember there is no way
beginning of the evening there is no way
for donald trump to get to 270 right
and they were right i got to 306.
306 to 223
306 to 223 that was a
it was
that was some evening and you know what
i'll tell you what i hate to say it and
i never thought i'd say it because
what happened there was legendary this
is a more important this is going to be
the most
important election in our country it's
history
so get out and vote in my second term i
will cut
middle-class taxes even more we have a
big tax cut
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and sleepy joe biden has pledged the
biggest tax hike in history
did anybody see 60 minutes last night
did anybody see 60 minutes
which is a total joke of the show but
you saw i released the thing early so
they got the full
but it was okay but did you see his
performance on that show
the only thing almost as bad was kamala
with the laughs
ah that's so funny she kept laughing i
said
is there something wrong with her too
she will not be the first woman
president you can't let that happen
no i said is there something wrong with
her she kept laughing
at very you know serious questions
but how about this mike was great but
how about this
they asked me she says are you ready for
tough questions
i thought she was kidding you know
because how do you say i said just treat
me for no no no
this is tough questions and i said they
do
and i said let's see what you have
and it was just question question kill
go
always going for the kill she's she's a
zippo but
always going for the kill and then did
you see the interview with him
oh it was so soft they're starting to
protect
they try so hard that's right you saw
the other day
he's walking out with ice cream
mr vice president what flavor is it
uh
it's i think it's vanilla and chocolate
i said i don't get questions like that
right
now pennsylvania gets it by the way we
win pennsylvania we win the whole thing
you got to get out here
big deal right congressman
this election is a choice between a
trump super recovery we're having a
super v it's called nobody even thought
we are doing numbers and where do you
see that number on gdp
i don't know what it is the fed said it
may be a 35
increase in gdp the atlanta fed
they came out last week you saw that
i'll take 25
right now i'll take 15 right now i think
the record was like seven or eight
but they said it could be 35 you see car
sales through the roof
housing starts through the roof there's
great things going on
but a tax increase by biden all the
things he wants to do regulations he
wants to put back
all the regulations which were terrible
it would take 20 years to get a highway
approved
20 years a job killer is right it's a
job killer
so you'd have that against a biden
depression let me tell you
if he gets in with what he wants to do
you will have a depression the likes of
which
we've never seen in this country outside
of perhaps
1929 it's a choice between
a trump boom or a biden lockdown he
wants to lock down the country again no
we understand the disease
well you guys i don't even talk to you
you're already locked out are you going
to ever open up
congressman are you going to get this
guy this clown to open it up
well make sure he can't get a site
make sure when the president comes into
pennsylvania
make sure he can't get aside he cannot
get a side i don't want him here we had
one they shut it down we had two made
three but i like this place this is
quite intimate
my guys did a good job at about four
hours notice they
like no but think of it think of it
though i said it before
so he doesn't want to step aside no
freedom of speech right
he doesn't want us to have a say but
this is the guy that's counting our
ballots
does it work it doesn't work so be very
vigilant
and watch be poll watchers watch
did you see where they fought us because
they didn't want poll watchers
they took us to court and we had a bad
decision
we had a judge just judge so we'll
appeal him
but this judge this judge obviously i
won't
i won't get too into that but he said no
you can't have poll watchers
so he's saying we can't even watch as
they count the ballots
but we're going to appeal it and we'll
end up winning we'll end up winning can
you believe it
we can't have poll watchers the judge
said they fought us on that they didn't
want people watching them count
who ever heard of a thing like this
before i came along nobody would have
sued
that's why romney got almost zero you
know when he
romney in philadelphia remember he got
he got almost zero votes
how do you get zero votes in the city
but we watch and we'll sue and we'll
keep doing it and we'll keep having law
enforcement
right alongside of us if joe biden
and his democrat socialists are elected
they will delay the vaccine
delay therapies prolong the pandemic
close your schools your schools have to
open
and shut down our country that doesn't
have a clue
this guy doesn't have a clue have you
seen what this i mean
we can't play with the country the only
thing i can tell you for sure
president xi from china president putin
from russia
kim jong-un north korea and i could name
40 others their sharpest attack
they don't want to deal with sleepy jail
one of them said to me one of the
leaders said well i hope you win because
we don't want to deal with somebody that
sleeps
all the time do you believe that no he
just announced the lid
he announced another lid
you know and he's not you know somebody
could say oh this is brilliant it's
prevent defense
first of all did you ever see prevent
defense that always loses
a team shuts down the other team for
three and
a half quarters they're leading by six
then they go prevent defense they lose
all the time right
two touchdowns scored on them they shut
a team down for the whole game
then they go let's go prevent well i
don't know if he's doing that i don't
think so
i think he's doing it because he can't
answer questions
really when these clowns back here
bad corrupt people when they ask him
questions
he cannot answer the simplest question
how about when they gave him questions
on a teleprompter
they said here are the questions and
they wrote out the answers to him
and he's responding can you imagine i
have the press here
sir what about this what about that what
about
i won't tell you some of the tough ones
because there are some
there are some questions that never work
out well no matter how you answer them
they can make whatever you know they'll
take the answer that could be perfect
and they'll make
so they'll ask a question and they said
let's see oh
well that means they gave them the
questions who ever heard of this before
and then the way the the tech
fakers close section 230 anybody
they closed down because the government
gave them special protection
the way they closed down anybody they
banned the new york
post from being on can you believe it
the new york post fourth largest man
no it's amazing in an interview that
aired last night
biden said he opposes letting young
americans resume their lives
even though most are at extremely low
risk
99.99 now as an example
i had it and here i am but my wife had
it
first lady had it but the legendary
baron trump had it
they say sir your son baron tested
positive i said oh that's terrible
like 14 minutes later how's barron oh
he's better he's fine
because they're stronger than us they
have an immune system i don't know what
the hell it is but
how's he doing 15 minutes how's he doing
he's fine sir
baron are you feeling okay nothing wrong
with me dad
i think he had the sniffles barely
99.98 of those under the age
50 fully recover but but sleepy joe
wants to keep the whole country locked
down
keep them in their homes while letting
rioters and looters run wild
you know we call these protests this is
not a meeting we call them protests you
know why
because the only thing you can do in
pennsylvania is a protest
you can't go to church you can't pray
to your god you can't be with your
pastors your priests your rabbis you
can't be
none of that you can't do anything you
can't go
shopping you can't open your stores but
if you want to protest and burn the hell
out of your city
no problem you can do that so
when i was told a couple of months ago
about pennsylvania and others
minnesota we're going to win too you
know we're going to win minnesota
because we saved minneapolis i sent in
the national guard took about a half an
hour
but we're gonna win that but when you
think about it
you can't do anything and then they have
this little clause
unless you're protesting i said good
so these are no longer rallies they are
friendly protests
[Applause]
when the china virus arrived we moved
heaven and earth to fight the disease we
banned travel from china and europe
sleepy joe didn't want to
he said oh you shouldn't do that your
xenophobe
right he called me racist too he called
me every that was in january
two months later he still thought he was
right and then he had to apologize
and then he did he runs and then he said
trump should have done it earlier
except he would no think of it how does
he get out of that one
and the fake news doesn't want to report
that so in january i wanted to do it
but in march he thought i should have
never done it
same with pelosi she was dancing in the
streets
nancy pelosi crazy nancy
crazy she's crazy as a bedbug
how about when she went to the beauty
parlor and the woman that owned the
beauty baller is a trump supporter can
you believe it
craziness oh what a group
we have a good chance of taking back the
house i'll tell you we have a good
chance
of course she's of course she's crazy we
airlifted medical supplies built
hospitals from scratch
slash red tape pioneered groundbreaking
therapies i wish cuomo in new york would
have used the convention center
for seniors you know if cuomo would have
used the convention center for seniors
and the big ship you know we sent the
big hospital ship in
sitting there practically empty all the
time he
if he would have used the ship and if he
would have used the convention center
for seniors we would have had nope you
would have had no problem there
we reduced the fatality rate 85
think of that that's because of what
we've come up with over the last little
while
as as i said before here i am right
and saved over 2 million american lives
so
when this first came people were
projecting that it could be as bad as
2.2 million right
i think we say by shutting down by doing
what we did by learning the disease and
now we have
therapies therapeutics we have all of
the different things the vaccines come
i really think we save two million lives
we get
they never say that the fake news will
never say that
and we will deliver 100 million doses of
a safe vaccine before the end of the
year
seniors will be first in line for the
vaccine because they're the most
vulnerable as you know we learned that
we must take the virus seriously we must
keep our people safe
but we must not give in to panic and
fear
they want me to say everybody everybody
oh please
we don't want to do that
most importantly we're protecting the
elderly and those with
underlying conditions with extreme
vigilance
this has been my top priority from the
beginning so we understand this
horrible disease sent by china came over
by china remember that don't forget that
please i will break through every op
oh do they want sleepy joe to win does
china want sleepy joe to win
they own him they own sleepy joe
did you see his email where they want 10
million dollars a year
a year for introductory purposes you
know who they're gonna introduce
him to sleepy jail so the son never made
10 cents
all of a sudden biden becomes vice
president and now he's making millions
of dollars a year
unbelievable and biden they got
and biden got a lot of it look he got 10
right
it went to the big man i don't consider
him a big man but it went to the big man
ten percent
and the press doesn't want to talk about
it
that's what
but we won't rest until we eradicate
this disease
once and for all i'm telling you it's
happening
we will vanquish the virus we will
overcome the pandemic
and we will emerge better stronger and
more unified than ever
[Music]
[Applause]
and by the way there are people who want
to get out and there are people that
feel more comfortable staying at home
that's okay stay
don't feel that stay it's okay
but if biden and the democrat socialists
are elected
they will raise your taxes to a level
that you've never seen before
quadruple he's the only candidate in
history
whose primary platform is i will raise
your taxes can you believe this
i'm running against this i am running
against
the worst candidate in the history of
presidential politics
i am i really believe that and think of
it
think of it and i have to be very
careful the way i say this you know what
if i say if i lose they go back we have
breaking news president trump thinks
he's going to lose they did it once
before
you know i told the same little anecdote
and they go back and they'll say
president trump thinks he's going to
decide to be very careful
but can you imagine can you even imagine
losing to a guy like this
actually i wish he was a good and even a
great candidate
because if something happened you feel a
little better
but could you imagine he can't remember
my name no i'm not that big of an ego
guy
he should be here but you know i'm the
candidate like that's
a good candidate and i'm happy to be
president he could not remember my name
yesterday this is what you're putting in
office
i don't think he's gonna make it i don't
think he's gonna make it
ladies and gentlemen the vice president
bye
we'll be doing a live today no i hear
he's doing the lid until thursday
hey media is it until thursday he's
doing the lit thursday
in other words he's taking 40 percent of
his campaign he's going to live
i don't know i don't know look you know
what you could run
see this beautiful whatever the hell
it's made out of plastic
see this beautiful thing you could run
that you got the democrats
you got the fake news media as their
partner and you have big tech they're
all partners and then you have the
rhinos
you have the rhinos you have the bad
republicans you have the sicko rhinos
right
that i've beaten so badly over the years
you know the rhinos the people that do
the ads and stuff
every one of those guys just about i
beat you because they all represented a
client
in the primaries and instead of saying
hey he did a good job he's a smart guy
he did a great job
they said let's go against them but
every one of those guys take a look real
garbage
not smart people but he wants to
terminate
religious liberty destroy the suburbs
he'll destroy i am
saving the suburbs i'm getting rid of a
regulation
i'm getting rid of a regulation that
will
move a project next to your beautiful
house congratulations
do you like having a nice project next
to your house i don't think so
and with it comes plenty of crime that's
why they keep saying
we don't know we think he's not doing
well with suburban women i think i'm
doing great with surprise
i am saving the suburbs
i'm saving the suburbs how can i do
badly look
here's what i know about suburban women
first of all they're great
they love our country but here's what i
know they want two things
they want to leave their house alone
they don't want a five-story
project next time or could be higher
they want to leave their household very
important and you know what else they
want security
okay they don't want to have antifa
and anarchists running for this race
okay
so if they agree with what i just said i
have a feeling they're going to be
voting for trump
[Music]
[Applause]
it was the same time last time remember
they said he will not get the women's
vote
he will not get the women's vote
and then at the end of the evening you
remember how great i did
right one of my best group women so i
said am i that bad
am i that bad he will not receive the
women's vote you know jim this should be
over very quickly
uh donald trump at that time it was just
donald no president
donald trump will not be able to get the
women vote
the end of the evening they said man did
he do well with the women vote what the
hell happened
[Music]
so true and then biden's going to pack
the supreme court with radical justices
who will shred your second amendment and
pro-life
and so many other things he will shred
it
to defend our god-given freedoms how do
you like amy by the way is it amy great
[Applause]
i nominated amy coney barrett
to the supreme court of the united
states
and tonight she will be confirmed by the
senate
and become the newest member of the
supreme
it's a court deal he wants to pack the
court maybe 16 maybe 18 maybe 20. why
don't you put a couple of hundred people
in there
he wants to pack up the court with
radical left judges
and i've been saying i've gone a step
further i have a list 45
great people great people they believe
in a thing called the constitution
you know little things like that he's
got to tell us who he might put on
because you can't vote for him unless
you know because you can't have
radical left judges who are looking to
destroy our country
this election day the people of
pennsylvania must stop
the anti-american radicals delivering
joe biden in the far left
you have to do this a thundering defeat
you have to deliver them a thundering
beautiful big solid defeat
you better get out there and vote you
know when i saw the few hands of the
people that voted that's in pennsylvania
for some reason you always vote very
late
i guess you're like me you feel like
voting in a booth
pressing a little button right
having somebody check to see that it
really is you there's
there is something nice about it right
but no but pennsylvania i think more
than any other place they want to vote
late
so i'm i'm really happy to see this
because you know what
a lot's been learned in the last few
days the debate
learned a lot we learned a lot about
fracking about energy
about the fact that he's not all there
no
that debate was important it had a lot
like super bowl type ratings right
i'm glad they didn't tell me that before
i went on stage
but that debate was great and we learned
other things we learned
when this savannah guthrie who is just
no she was she was coming out of her
chair as she was asking she was
she was she was crazed
jesus christ and i did a nice job
savannah take it easy just relax
just relax don't let the hatred show but
we learned a lot you learned a lot and
i'm glad you're getting ready to vote
and we've got to blow them out this is
the whole ballgame we got to blow them
out
[Applause]
and maybe above all else joe biden as
you know
is a corrupt politician they've known
that for a long time
now they'll never put that on air they
will say cut the cameras
he called joe biden corrupt cut cut cut
we have to protect joe
you know they have big benefits when joe
if joe gets in they get a lot of
benefits that they won't get with me
he wants to destroy your energy jobs in
pennsylvania while his own son collected
183 dollars a month
183 000 a month
so hunter has no energy experience
he has no job he has no income
his father becomes vice president and
here's just a few of the things he gets
183 000 a month would anybody like that
job
for a very bad type reputation
big energy company from ukraine right
he gets three and a half million dollars
from russia
from the wife of the mayor of moscow
three and a half million dollars what
the hell did he do for that
he had no income no job no nothing
and then come the beauties he got 1.5
billion to manage because he's a great
manager of money
he had no job no money no no 1.5 billion
dollars to manage which is millions and
millions of dollars from china
i said to a friend of mine the biggest
on wall street very smart guy i said
is that possible to get that he said
it's not possible for my firm to get it
he got one and took him approximately 10
minutes of dealing with the chinese
and then they were going for the big one
10 million dollars a year
for introductory purposes and when i say
it
they go but you have no proof no we do
we have stuff all over
but then they have a new excuse a new
excuse
russia it was russia
right here we go again three years of it
adam schiff the watermelon head right
upon information i believe i believe
that the laptop from hell
was created by russia
uh i'll tell you why some of these
foreign countries they must think
they must think shifty shift they must
think we are nuts
think of it after going through all that
no collusion they spent 48 million
dollars no collusion
by people that hated me if they had a
stamp
that had an r on it they would have said
it's collusion
smart people 18 crazy democrats that
were smart
vicious violent no collusion
48 million they spent and now
we hear about the laptop the laptop from
hell
that he brought in to be fixed he forgot
that was a very expensive
that was a very expensive repair job he
didn't pick it up
by the time he picked it up it was too
late but here's the thing
and they say it's russia russia russia i
hope every
does anybody here believe it was russia
you know who doesn't believe it even
more than you is the fake news media but
they'll write it all the time
it's a con job it was the greatest crime
in the history of our country and this
could be the second we caught them
spying in my campaign
it was a treasonous act and we caught
them we have them
let's see what happens you know we have
very nice people
we have very nice people they don't want
to do anything before the election
very nice very nice people it's okay to
do it to me but it's not okay to do it
to other people
if biden wins china wins and if china
has anything to do with this whole deal
if he wins let me tell you china will
own
the united states of america
when we win you win pennsylvania wins
and america wins we're gonna have a big
victory
i don't think china likes me too much
you know i've charged you
tens of billions of dollars billions and
billions of dollars in
in uh taxes and in all sorts of things
tariffs
and i give 28 billion to the farmers
there aren't a lot of farmers here i
guess right
are you a farmer did you get a check
he's a farmer i got one farmer here but
no but i gave it to the farmers because
they were targeted by
china 28 billion dollars two years 12
and 16.
28 billion dollars i gave to our farmers
because they were targeted nobody else
did that
what you would like is i charged a big
tax on the dumped steel right they were
dumping steel all over the place
destroying your steel companies i put a
25
tariff on that and your steel company
started doing well again it was very
nice sleepy joe won't do
that in fact sleepy joe said you know we
made a very good deal with china
unfortunately the ink wasn't dry before
the plague came
in but i never took the tariffs off
nobody understands that never took it
off i wouldn't take that
sleepy joe said one of the first things
i do is take the tariffs off oh
do you think china would like to see him
get in boy oh boy
they uh they would love to see it if i
don't
sound like a typical washington
politician it's because i'm not a
politician
if i don't always play by the rules of
the washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you harder than
anyone ever before
[Music]
so we have a couple of warriors here
they're great people they're congressmen
and
man that they fight for me congressman
dan
muser dan thank you very much dad
a former congressman i'm sure you never
heard of him
his name is lou barletta
[Applause]
[Music]
and lou barletta is strongly against
taking the statues of
christopher columbus down would you say
that's right
lou's not a big fan of that right and
congressional
candidate who is supposed to be
fantastic and a star lisa
sheller
[Applause]
good that's great lisa
and somebody has done a fantastic job
campaign
chair bernie comfort ernie
bernie hey bernie how are we doing
looks good looks good looks very good
harder to judge because you know you go
in so late but it's looking good
the places where they've casting and
where they're casting their vote
that's not any more polling you sort of
know they they are really looking good
bernie you got to win you don't win i'll
fire you so fast you have no idea
i especially want to recognize the
incredible truckers for trump
who are here tonight truckers
[Music]
the truckers for trump they're
incredible people actually
i don't know how they do it those are
long hours driving down those highways
huh
[Applause]
[Music]
and we got him some pretty good
legislation that other people wouldn't
get him because they just don't do those
things but
we got him some pretty good legislation
so thank you very much fellas we
appreciate it and
the women and the men under my
leadership
we achieved the most secure border in
united states history my opponent's
insane immigration plan would eliminate
u.s borders entirely by implementing
nationwide catch and release they want
to have catcher you know what cancer
releases you catch them
they're a murderer they're a reminiscent
you release them you know where you
release them into our country
then biden at the debate he said no no
it's okay because they come back for
court nobody comes back
they don't come back they don't know i
ended catch and release i didn't like
catching a murderer and releasing them
no that wasn't
we keep them out we're keeping them out
you can come into our country but you
have to come in legally and you have to
come in
through merit his plan would also make
every community into a sanctuary city
for violent criminals
somebody like your governor tom wolf
would probably love it
you got to speak to him about this you
can't do this kind of stuff
called freedom of speech right the biden
harris plan would also increase refugees
coming into our country by more than
700 percent it would be the highest
level
anywhere in the world that's that's
bernie
that's crazy burning they pledge to
terminate all national security travel
bans opening the floodgates to
radical islamic terrorism no thank you
if you don't mind joe no thank you you
saw what happened a few days ago in
paris right you saw that horrible at
that
i'm keeping the terrorist jihadist and
violent
extremists the hell out of our country
is that okay
do the truckers agree
do the truckers agree i think so i think
that
i think i have the trucker's vote that's
nice
by the way nice trucks
you think i could hop into one of them
and drive it away i'd love to
just drive the hell out of here just get
the hell out of this i had such a good
life
my life was great and then i said let's
do this darling this will be a lot of
fun
but you know what i'm so happy with it
because
nobody has ever done so much in the
first three and a half years no
administration
we invested 2.5 trillion with a t
trillion dollars
see now biden would say 2.5 million
2.5 000.
thank you and i love you too thank you
i guess why i guess that's why we're all
doing it together right when you get
right down to it
we have a great country we have to save
our country most important election
but we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in
the u.s military
and we saved a thing called the
philadelphia shipyard have you ever
heard of it
we said anybody worked there we saved
the philadelphia shipyard we didn't want
to lose it
we also passed va choice and va
accountability nobody said it was
possible
for the vets and we just got a 91
approval rating from the vets the
highest ever
remember all for years you'd always see
vet stories how badly they were treated
now you go see a doctor we pay the bill
if you can't
because we have great doctors there
actually but a lot of times it would
take weeks before you could see a doctor
and now you go to a private doctor we
paid the bill
nobody thought we could do that exactly
one year ago today
we killed the leader of isis al-baghdadi
[Applause]
and we took out the world's number one
terrorist
salamani is dead
and we took 100 of the isis caliphate
you know that 100
[Applause]
i withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous
iran nuclear deal one of the worst
stupidest deals
this was john kerry who liked to go
bicycle riding remember
that's the only thing that stopped him
from finishing the deal sooner
so they paid 150 billion dollars
1.8 billion in green in cash for
nothing for an agreement that expires
very shortly if we didn't terminate it
you know time flies right for a short
term they gave 150 billion dollars
the first call i get when we win will be
from the head of iran
let's make a deal their economy is
crashing
they will call and i want them to do
well but they cannot have a nuclear
weapon if it's okay with you
if it's okay with you they cannot have a
nuclear weapon do we agree with that
congressman
[Applause]
but we want them to do well but it'll be
the first call
i said we don't want to negotiate they
got to see what happens because they
dream well so china dreams
every country is dreaming about it
germany you know there was a poll that
barack hussein obama is more popular in
germany
than i am but i agree with that
if i win those polls then i'm not doing
my job right you know when you think
about
it no they rip us everybody rips us
i recognize the true capital of israel
and opened the american embassy in
jerusalem
that was promised for decades and
decades by
every single president running for
office promised that and nobody did it
but me
instead of right i've been i'm the only
one
instead of never-ending wars we are
forging peace
in the middle east
[Applause]
three countries and they're lined up
they're lined up
so beautiful to see no blood in the sand
much less expensive now we just got
yesterday sudan you saw that
got bahrain uae
no great they're lined up they're all
set you know what they're tired
they're tired of fighting all the time
they're tired
we're bringing our soldiers back from
afghanistan all coming back
many have already come back a vote for
republicans
19 years is enough do you agree 19. a
vote for republicans is a vote for safe
communities
great jobs and the american dream
[Music]
to vote for the americans and in
conclusion i hate to leave you but in
conclusion
over the next four years we will make
america
into the manufacturing superpower of the
world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all it's already happening
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults on law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
second amendment
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
we've never had i said 2.5 trillion
we have the greatest tanks and rockets
and missiles
and jets super stealth
and tankers and submarines and our
nuclear
weapons are now tippy top and hope to
god
you never have to use them but we are
the envy of the world we are the envy of
the world
russia china north korea no matter where
you go
our weapons are the envy of the world
hope to god we never have to use it
but we will ensure peace through
strength we will maintain american
energy independence we're independent
can you believe that we have energy
independence
first time we will end surprise medical
billing
require price transparency already
signed ready to go january first
lower drug prices even more we have
favored nations we get the lowest in the
world now with the highest we go down to
the lowest
the drug companies don't exactly love me
too much big pharma
they are doing more commercials than me
than biden times five
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students and restore patriotic
education
to our school
[Applause]
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great
american plan
[Applause]
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust in god
you know they wanted to take the word
god out of their
pledge of allegiance you saw them and i
watched and i said oh they must
have made a typo they didn't have
in god they didn't have god they took
the word god out
i said once and then when i watched it a
second time same thing happened i said
this is serious
and then our country got very angry and
it was incredible how quickly
god got put back into right
and put back pledge of allegiance
[Applause]
thank you everybody thank you
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for pennsylvania
[Applause]
you know a man named byron york he's a
great writer i find him to be a great
writer they know him very well
he did an article today that would say
who's going to win he said i don't know
but
you have these incredible rallies and
i'm not just talking about trump rallies
that just form car rallies boat rallies
or they just form without
by the way trucker rallies they have
trucker rallies
and it was very interesting he said and
it's true they're
organic they just happened they had a
big one
they had a big one yesterday on long
island they had a big one in new york
city
and he said it's very interesting you
had a big one here yeah
no he said uh yeah i don't know he said
he said you better be careful
you better be careful because he's never
seen anything like it and i'm not even
talking about the rallies that we do i'm
talking about these are rallies
in iowa they had thousands of tractors
their tractors
the boat rallies are incredible for the
last four years you have seen me fight
for you
and now i am relying on you to deliver
another historic victory
for our country
on november 3rd we must finish the job
and drain the swamp once and for all we
did it
but nobody told me the swamp was that
deep and that dirty and that vicious
you get impeached for a perfect phone
call they impeach you for a perfect
perfect phone call and by the way they
had the
laptop as i call it the laptop from hell
and based on that laptop they should
have never impeached right
but they didn't want to reveal a little
thing like that no it was great
and we had great loyalty from the
republican party great great loyalty
it was really great get your friends get
your family get your neighbors and get
your co-workers and
get the hell out to vote please
you know what it's going to be all over
the country not just in pennsylvania
well
it's going to be a great red wave
they're already talking about it
boom and it's going to be a lot bigger
than people understand and that's what
byron was talking about he said you know
i don't know there's never been there's
never been anything there have never
been rallies like this there have never
we were in ohio we're in wisconsin
yesterday we were in uh new hampshire it
was
i'm telling you you had to see the
biggest rallies anyone's ever seen
and they go quickly you know we give
like 24 hours notice press a button
we're going to be we're going to be in
new hampshire we're going to be in ohio
wisconsin
we're going to be some place and boom
you have tens of thousands of people
there's never been that before
you know sleepy joe goes out there's
like four people showed they have no
people
they can't even fill up the circles you
know the circles
and barack hussein obama went out over
the last three four days he's drawing
flies
flies nobody's going
obama's out and they will never show it
you know they don't turn
see here they never show the extent of
it they have the opposite
they never show it they should show it
because nobody is showing up to watch
barack who's saying obama see the red
lights
see those red lights all those red
lights that means you're on live
are you ready oh they just turned them
off because i was insulting
look they just went off can you believe
[Music]
it
you know they're tormented the fake news
they're tormented
in one way in one way they have to have
it on because it's ratings it's big big
beautiful ratings
in another way cnn hates when i say
cnn is fake corrupt news say hey
so you'll see it go on and off a little
bit no they just went off did you see
that bomb
any time i start talking they sort of
say let's go to a commercial break now
please
no they're tormented because they want
the ratings without it they get terrible
ratings
they want the ratings they're fantastic
ratings but at the same time
they don't want to be talked about in a
bad manner right
but you have to talk about them because
they're corrupt they have to report the
news
they are the enemy of the people they
really are they're the enemy of the
people
for generations america's destiny was
made
and forged and won in places like
bethlehem and bristol
it's granted and by the way he has
nothing to do with scranton
altoona easton and allentown
they were tough american men and strong
american women
who gave their hearts sweat and soul for
their families
their country and for freedom we stand
on the shoulders of the pennsylvania
patriots
who fought the battles mined the call
worked the assembly lines loaded the
rail cars
poured the steel that built the middle
class it built the middle class
raised up our great skyscrapers laid
down the battleships won two world wars
defeated fascism and communism and made
america
into the single greatest nation in the
history of the world and the best
is yet to come
[Applause]
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power to you
the american people with your help
your devotion and your drive we are
going to keep on working
we are going to keep on fighting and we
are going to keep on
winning winning winning
[Applause]
[Music]
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god and
together with the incredible people of
pennsylvania
we have made america powerful again
our military our military
we have made america wealthy again
our stock market your 401ks let's keep
them up there
don't throw them away in two years and
you'll say huh
the president told the previous
president told me that was going to
happen
i don't think that's going to happen
your 401ks are hitting records does
anybody have a 401k
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you pennsylvania go
and vote
thank you
[Music]
oh
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
oh
ah
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
oh
you